ronnie lived a whole other sort of life
than me like i wasn't into cars i wasn't
the cb
radio we actually would pick up girls
off the cb radio like
you would talk to them and then you know
you would set up a thing to go meet them
and stuff like that and it was kind of
cool
getting laid back then was like pulling
off a heist i mean you had to get on the
cb
radio yeah it was fun
yeah that was how i met my friend
shitbox ritchie remember
shitbox richard rest in peace richie
pervy pete
i met him on cb radio oh no [ __ ] he was
a good guy
made lifelong friends his claim to fame
was when he was driving a limo
[ __ ] in a box he picked up some rabbi he
picked up a rabbi at the airport and it
was [ __ ] up
he had to drive him to brooklyn to
williamsburg and the guy went
you know into his house and he he was
changing his clothes or whatever
and yet richie had to drive him
somewhere else into the city afterwards
you're forgetting the big part of it
what richie rings the doorbell for the
rabbi and he says excuse me uh rabbi
i have to go to the bathroom can i use
your bathroom rabbit tells him no
because oh yeah right right yeah
remember that part of it yeah yeah yeah
and richie's like this guy's a religious
guy and he won't even let me use his
bathroom
so richie goes back to the car grabs
this box he carries for emergencies and
he took the box in the back of the limo
and [ __ ] in the box and then yeah
the whole [ __ ] car stunk you're
forgetting a big part of this
you remember everything man i don't know
because the guy's dead if i don't
remember his whole legacy is gone
you got it's an important part of the
story so richie's [ __ ] in the box
and all of a sudden the rabbi starts
banging on the glass to get in the car
oh no and richie has to rush his [ __ ]
and then richie realized the car stinks
so richie gets out the other side of the
door he flings the
[ __ ] out and the rabbi gets in with the
[ __ ] smell in the car from shitbox
richie
that was the big story yeah good times
good times
you